the desert is still the night seems
endless silent and at peace until it's
pierced by the sound of gunshots and
screams
deep in the Sahara the s iesta
Foundation is Waging War against a newly
discovered enemy a squad of foundation
agents is retreating trying to get away
from the ones who massacred their allies
they were attempting to eliminate the
threat using conventional means but
their rifles were no match for the
reality-bending entities of the kingdom
of Abaddon the retreating agents cover
one another as they make their way back
to the extraction point the enemy Force
advances agents that are caught too
close to the Sorcerers of Abaddon
disintegrated to thin air this is not an
enemy they can defeat the SCP agents
need to get back to base and relay what
they have found to their superiors
out of the hundreds of Agents sent into
the Sahara that night only a handful
make it out alive they are debriefed by
their superiors at the foundation who
classified the anomalous humanoids under
the highest of threat levels the kingdom
of Abaddon is a threat the kingdom of
Abaddon must be eliminated
reconnaissance done prior to the
disastrous Mission had alerted the
foundation to the presence of anomalies
in the region but they had no idea how
strong the anomalous humanoids would be
from data gathered through old reports
it seemed like the Abaddon humanoids
were responsible for the deaths of no
fewer than 75 Foundation personnel and
had stolen at least 12 different items
from the foundation the leaders of the
SCP Foundation tasked research team
omega-5 with developing a weapon that
would be capable of destroying the
kingdom of Abaddon once and for all the
weapon they are researching must be
capable of long-range destruction
because the moment any foundation agent
gets close to the area they are
vaporized by the reality manipulating
powers of its inhabitants
the project is given the name twins of
God and is led by a foundation doctor
known only by the designation
051 o51 is popular in the SCP Foundation
well known for his in-depth research and
charismatic personality making him the
perfect person to lead such a project
and o51 recently came across an anomaly
that he believes holds the solution the
foundation has been looking for to
defeat the kingdom of Abaddon item 001
and so the omega-5 team gets to work
they discover that the anomaly has
incredible Powers when put inside a host
which they refer to as an item 001
entity and set up a series of
experiments using different people to
harness its energy the first series of
tests all end in tragedy the anomaly
causes the entity it inhabits to become
intensely radioactive anyone who gets
close to it succumbs to immediate
radiation sickness and eventually death
to stop the radiation problems the
omega-5 research group intensifies the
containment procedures o51 receives
reports from the higher-ups that the
kingdom of Abaddon has attacked another
Foundation facility in Sudan long-range
defense is needed ASAP the administrator
puts more pressure on omega-5 and
especially its leader 051 to solve the
problems of item 001 and develop a
weapon that can save the foundation he
stays awake for days on end working
tirelessly to create a safe and
controllable item 001 entity although
there are signs that the weapon work it
is still unpredictable when item 001 is
initiated the host entity becomes
paralyzed suffers severe cerebral
hemorrhaging and soon a new host is
needed before testing Can Begin Again
and that's not the only thing that goes
wrong
whenever the anomaly is put into a new
host sudden and random destruction of
on-site structures and Personnel take
place o51 knows though that if this
power can be harnessed and controlled in
the right way that it could be the
weapon that the foundation needs to wipe
out the kingdom of Abaddon once and for
all in order to control item 001 o51 has
a mind kill switch implanted in its
host's brains o51 can activate the
implant to incapacitate its host and
immediately Stop The Unwanted
destruction countless hosts are
terminated by this mine kill switch in
the early trials conducted by the
omega-5 team but progress continues to
be made and eventually a hypothesis is
formulated perhaps the disastrous side
effects of item 001 can be offset by
spreading the anomaly across multiple
subjects they theorize that the immense
mental load of the anomaly can be
distributed among several hosts thus
reducing the toil it takes on each and
giving them the ability to control its
immense power but o51 and the omega-5
team more data and for that they need
more bodies they consult with the
director of site 17 and it is concluded
that the nearby town of San Marco would
be an appropriate place to get the
additional test subjects they require on
a quiet Sunday morning
omega-5 along with support from a squad
of armed SCP agents Storm Into the San
Marcos de la Vida sterna Church during
the middle of mass
they gather up a number of the younger
congregants and bring them back to the
site where item 001 is housed the
researchers quickly ran through their
new supply of test subjects though and
omega-5 would need to get even more if
their research was to continue
instead of going back and forth between
the testing facility and San Marcos 051
decided to move the entire item 001
operation to the town itself he renames
the town testing site 001 and Omega 5
rounds up 23 of the healthiest subjects
they can find for use in the next series
of research tests a few weeks after
occupying the town of San Marco
omega-5 makes its most substantial
progress yet just as they theorized by
spreading out the anomaly of item 001
across a specific group of hosts that
can control its powers the test may have
cost the lives of almost everyone in the
town
but the ends certainly justify the means
the kingdom of Abaddon poses an
existential threat to the SCP Foundation
after all and thanks to This research
they will soon have a weapon capable of
bringing them Victory the foundation
administer criticized o51's methods but
can't argue with his results
unfortunately 051 has a dark secret a
secret that disturbs even the most
hardened and loyal members of omega-5 a
secret that has to do with the item 001
hosts the host that omega-5 has made its
major progress with are not the ordinary
test subjects normally used by the
foundation no the test subjects 051
makes his breakthrough with are children
nine of them to be exact all between 4
and 11 years old despite being told
specifically by the foundation
administrator to only test on adults the
research required 051 to break the chain
of command and follow the science down
the path it led the children are
contained in a reinforced bunker where
only 051 and the select few have access
they are technically alive but are
functionally brain dead a group of nine
children share a hive mind that can
process information and more importantly
can unleash the full potential of the
implanted anomaly creating and
controlling a devastating power but not
everyone is thrilled with what they've
achieved members of omega-5 are haunted
by the screens of the children that they
force to be part of their weapons
development program they describe their
merging with item 001 as being a process
that rips out their souls and replaces
them with something much more Sinister
in fact all of omega-5 regret what they
have been a part of and what they've
done
all except 0-5-1 the nine children can
Channel unprecedented amounts of energy
from an unknown origin that omega-5
hypothesizes comes from an extra
dimensional source which is used to
unbind atoms at the quantum level when
the right activation words are spoken it
appears as though this tremendous power
gives the children the ability to
annihilate anything in the entire
universe it's a gun to end all guns and
only o51 has the key to control it the
nine children work so well with an item
001 that omega-5 reclassifies it to
include the nine children themselves
they are not just the entity housing or
controlling item 001 they permanently
become item 001 once omega-5 has a
better understanding of item 001 they
begin to run tests to find out the full
extent of its abilities first they test
the distance item 001 can reach the
initial test that Omega 5 carries out is
on a steel rod placed five kilometers
away 051 orders the children to destroy
the target moments later the phone next
to o51 begins to ring when he picks it
up the Observer tasked with washing the
pole is on the other end he informs051
that the steel rod has been completely
vaporized o51 is not satisfied though he
has another pole sent out this time
placed 8 000 kilometers away from the
nine children 051 asked the children to
destroy that Rod almost immediately the
phone rings again the target has been
vaporized
0.051 smiles the next series of tests
Omega 5 runs on item 001 are to
determine the maximum size of an object
that can be destroyed the tests start
out with a steel sphere three meters in
diameter placed 1 000 kilometers from
item 001 051 orders the children to
destroy the object it is instantly
vaporized o51 has seen enough small
tests it's time for something big
so he does something that will later be
questioned by everyone at the SCP
Foundation he orders the nine children
to destroy a church of the broken God
worship site in Turkey not long after
the destruction order is given to item
001 reports begin coming in the worship
site has been obliterated with no
observable damage to the surrounding
area
deadly and precise 051 closes his eyes
and takes a deep breath he looks as if
he's overcome by an immense spiritual
experience he opens his eyes leans over
to the children and Whispers the name
later that day 051 finds out that the
target he had named has been vaporized
the success of omega-5 in item 001 is
relayed to the administration of the
foundation they are so impressed that
they make plans to use item 001 to
eliminate the Abaddon threat once and
for all however one of the heads of the
foundation administrator Williams has
major concerns about the way o51 is
running the program the updates that 051
has been sending have become less
scientific and more philosophical more
spiritual administrator Williams sends a
letter to o51 reassuring him that he is
doing good work but once the mission to
destroy the kingdom of Abaddon is
completed 051 will be promoted to
director and reassigned to the newly
constructed site-19 for the good of the
foundation and maybe the rest of the
world he'll be permanently moved away
from item zero zero one o51's response
is short and
I am fine administrator the project is
finished we will complete our task when
you arrive
administrator Williams arrives at
site-001 a few days later he is greeted
by o51 and the omega-5 team Williams
can't help but notice that 051 has a
strange look in his eyes it is the look
of a crazed man who has been lost in his
work and who has perhaps lost himself
Williams puts the thought away though
and walks with o51 and his accompanying
agents to the viewing area where the
powers of item 001 will be demonstrated
administrator Williams and the other
agents watch from a protected viewing
room as 051 enters the Chamber of his
new super weapon it's time to see if
their weapon that has had so much time
effort sweat tears and especially blood
poured into it will have been worth it
everyone watches as o51 leans over and
says the name of the avadon Citadel to
the nine children all at once they start
to Glow no one observing can see what
has happened in the far-off Kingdom but
they know something big has happened the
administrator is thrilled but notices
something
051 hesitated the moment while leaning
over the children before standing back
up did he whisper something else to them
and then administrator Williams
vaporizes pulled apart at an atomic
level before he has the chance to scream
what's going on the agent standing next
to where administrator Williams
previously existed began to yell and
pull out their guns they burst through
the door of the observation room and run
down the hallway towards where 051 and
the nine children are located the arm
agents rush into the room but 051 is
gone
children are still over the next few
weeks 051 is reported to be seen several
times by SCP agents however no one is
able to catch him and it appears as
though other members of the SCP
Foundation have also gone AWOL as well
perhaps joining him on the run it is
unclear what his plan is but the reports
from the reconnaissance team sent into
the Sahara make it obvious what the
result of his first command to the
children was there isn't a single
humanoid or building left in the Kingdom
of Abaddon
but even with this Victory the highest
levels of the SCP Foundation have an
ominous thought lurking in the back of
their minds where did o51 go and what is
he planning to do next
following the improper use of item 001
leading to the untimely death of a
high-ranking foundation staff member the
weapon was deemed too dangerous and
containment procedures were implemented
due to the high amount of radiation they
were found to emit the nine children
were placed into lead-lined bags and
buried under 50 meters of concrete
beneath the Church of San Marcos de la
Vida Eterna
though all the children continued to be
functionally brain dead they still
display Signs of Life despite their
containment and by order of the overseer
Council have been classified as a
formula entity the smell of fire and oil
fills the air the sound of gears
grinding can be heard between the
explosions and shrieks of Terror a man
runs out of his house only to have his
leg grabbed by a metal arm and dragged
back through his front door
scp-001 leaves a trail of metal
fragments and mechanical Parts on the
ground in the wake of its destruction
iron chains swing from its form cast
iron gears whirl within it a glowing
light throbs from the center of its body
scp-001 is consuming everything in its
path after incorporating the truck
chassis into its being
scp-001 rolls in a lumbering fashion to
the next house it rips the gutters from
the side of the building residents who
live in the air area flee their
neighborhood all the while hoping that
the mechanical monstrosity skips over
their house so they have something to
return to if they make it out alive a
section of scp-001's undercarriage drops
away from the main body it rolls down
the street consuming more and more
material the new entity resembles a
human's spine and rib cage it topples
over unable to support itself the
rib-like formations extend out to grab
anything and everything within reach the
newly Incorporated material forms what
can only be described as a head light
from within the eye sockets fixate on
nearby civilians the metallic creature
picks up the people and places them
inside its exposed steel rib cage then
it turns and spots a woman helplessly
trying to crawl away the creature
reaches out with a spiked tentacle and
wraps it around the woman's body she is
placed inside of the chest cavity
moments later a severed hand falls out
of the entity and onto the ground the
mechanical monster continues to gather
bodies and materials incorporating them
into its frame a growth begins to slowly
expand on its back it becomes so massive
that the creature Falls over and uses
its limbs to Scurry to a nearby house
there is a sickening crunching sound as
the growth bursts from within emerges
three humanoid creatures resembling the
civilians that the entity had consumed
earlier a female with chains extending
from her scalp like dreadlocks stumbles
away the second humanoid is a man with
cogs for limbs he examines the
clock-like components that have been
incorporated into his body then stares
blankly into the distance the third
humanoid lies motionless on the ground
he did not make it the two functioning
humanoids look at their creator intently
for a moment nothing moves then as if
they have been given orders
telepathically the half human half
machine humanoids turn and run away from
the Mayhem a few weeks before the
massacre caused by what would be
designated as scp-001 the Foundation had
been in contact with the Allied occult
initiative there were rumors of an
anomalous object in Mexico being
worshiped by a group of people who
identified themselves as the Church of
the broken God Intel about the church
claimed their deity was a small
mechanical box filled with cogs and
pistons the Box supposedly had
supernatural abilities it was said to be
able to communicate with congregants of
the Church of the broken God
telepathically The Devout worship the
Box following any order it gave and in
return they were filled with an emotion
that could be only described as Divine
as World War II rages on in Europe the
foundation sends agents to recover
anomalies in Mexico that might help with
the war effort while there the
foundation force is tasked with learning
about the Church of the broken God they
are also ordered to investigate a town
near La Paz where there are troubling
accounts of a mechanical anomalous
creature causing Mayhem the agents make
their way through Mexico Gathering
various objects to bring back to
Foundation sites in the United States
the unit loads all the anomalies they
were covered onto a train with a plan to
check out the stories of the mechanical
anomaly they've heard about as they make
their way to the U.S border the train
heads North along rusted rails just
outside La Paz they've come across a
broken down train filled with what looks
to be refugees when the foundation unit
goes to investigate they find all the
refugees repeating the same words over
and over again but they don't understand
the foundation agents look at one
another confused until one of them
translates the words into English the
words the refugees are saying over and
over again are La Machina the machine
the commanding officer orders a squad of
foundation agents to proceed up the
tracks to see if they can figure out
what has the refugees so scared they
make their way towards La Paz
disappearing Over the Horizon as the sun
sets the remaining Foundation agents
hear gunshots in the distance they stay
awake all night remaining Vigilant
waiting for the exploratory Squad but
morning
without anyone returning three days
later the foundation Force still has not
seen anything since the exploratory
Squad left then as the sun sits lazily
in the morning Sky a lone figure is
spotted walking down the tracks towards
the trains one of the agents on watch
blows his whistle and points to the
figure a squad of Agents rushes towards
the shadow of a man their guns are
raised ready for anything the figure
drops to the ground and begins to crawl
along the tracks the agents reach the
Fallen man only to find that he is one
of their squad mates who has been sent
up the tracks to investigate La Paz
several days before the agent's name is
DeMarco he is covered in blood his
clothes are in tatters and he has lost a
boot DeMarco lies on his back with
Foundation agents standing around him
his eyes are wide and wild he keeps
babbling on about a world eater how the
rest of his Squad had been mulched and
he is the only one who made it out alive
the foundation agents carry DeMarco back
to the makeshift base they created by
the trains they need to figure out way
to get the Convoy moving again but
whatever is up ahead has already taken
out an entire Foundation Squad it had to
be something anomalous but what could it
possibly be the unit of foundation
agents prepare to move towards La Paz
they start loading their rifles and
check the amount of ammunition and
explosives available in case the
containment process gets out of hand
just as they are about to leave the base
a convoy appears on the horizon it is an
Allied occult initiative Force preparing
to attack whatever it is that is
devastating La Paz this organization's
mission is to not secure contain or
protect but to destroy the foundation
may be in over their heads on this one
and the Joint Force with the Allied
occult initiative may be the only way to
stop what is now known as
scp-001 the aoi and Foundation Force
gears up for battle they set out for La
Paz and what they find causes them to
Quake with fear
scp-001 has consumed so much material it
is the size of a mountain it moves like
a a tidal wave of mechanical destruction
washing over the buildings and Landscape
under it whatever
scp-001 passes over is consumed and
added to its massive body
scp-001 started as a small mechanical
box with cogs but now has morphed into a
gigantic metal death machine the Church
of the broken God has finally met their
maker as the small entity they once
worshiped has now consumed all of its
members their God is an all-consuming
monster the aoi and Foundation forces do
everything they can to stop scp-001 from
continuing its reign of Destruction they
fire barrage after barrage of bullets
and explosives into the mechanical
anomaly they bring in air support to try
and damage it from the skies but nothing
works the aoi uses an artifact in their
possession to lure scp-001 to the coast
of the Pacific Ocean where a trap has
been set for the so-called God the
Monstrous mechanical creature moves
slowly to towards the water it consumes
abandoned cars buildings and boats as it
approaches the coastline it even shovels
large amounts of Earth into its form
causing Flames to spurt out from its
inner workings smoke Bellows from
openings between different mechanical
components like a volcano before it is
about to erupt suddenly seemingly from
nowhere a massive cloud with a reddish
tint appears in the sky Air Raid Sirens
can be heard in the distance the
enormous Cloud begins to pulsate streaks
of lightning shoot through the Red Mist
in the sky it now sits directly over
scp-001 from within the cloud part of a
ship can be seen it appears to be
slightly damaged electricity flows over
its Hull the vessel in the giant Red
Cloud is classified as
scp-2399 the underside of the vessel
begins to Glow aqua blue a blinding beam
of light is ejected from
scp-2399 which penetrates straight down
and through as
cp001 for a moment everything is still
there is complete silence then as if
scp-001 is trying to reach up and grab
the vessel above it a mechanical bulge
reaches out before scp-001 can grab the
vessel above there is another bright
flash of light
scp-2399 blinks out of existence the
sound of grinding gears can be heard
coming from within
scp-001 it begins to shed its outer
layers of metal then the entire
structure that was
scp-001 collapses into the water and
onto the beach giant cogs fall from the
sky parts of vehicles embed themselves
in the sand as the foundation and aoi
agents approach the piles of scrap metal
and mechanical components they see that
some of them are still moving it is as
if an invisible power source is still
pulsating through some of the Machinery
the Agents of the foundation celebrate
the destruction of the giant mechanical
beast but little do they know this was
only a piece of the entity worshiped as
the broken God the Foundation agents
collect as many of the still moving
Parts as they can they find spinning
gears twitching pulleys and firing
Pistons as the parts are separated from
one another and carried away from the
main wreckage of scp-001 they slowly
stop moving and become inactive some of
the artifacts were covered were
identified as being connected to the
Church of the broken God these artifacts
are found closer to the middle of what
was once a mountain-sized
scp-001 hundreds of anomalous artifacts
are collected and transported to SCP
Foundation sites collecting the broken
parts of scp-001 is relatively safe
however some agents get too close to the
larger moving Parts getting caught in
them and losing a body part or two but
most agents proceed with caution and
survive the collection ordeal with their
arms and legs still attached to their
bodies dive teams are sent into the
water to recover parts that have sunk to
the Bottom of the Sea one of the divers
is a local from the area he is hired to
bring up the heart of the machine since
he is an experienced diver used to free
diving to Great depths to collect
oysters from the bottom of the bay the
diver enters the water and swims down
into the murky depths he secures straps
around the heart of scp-001 and pulls
hard on the Rope as an indication to the
surface that it is ready to be hauled up
the Salvage team on the surface begins
to pull there is a second slight tug on
the Rope then it goes slack the team
continues to pull when they get the
heart to the surface they are horrified
at what else comes up with it tangled in
the ropes is the lifeless body of the
diver his head is smashed between two
moving pieces of the heart it looks as
if he shoved his head between the slabs
of metal himself the Salvage team
untangles the Body Rolls it off the deck
and back into the ocean the mechanical
box which was the heart of scp-001 is
offloaded on the shore but as the
foundation prepares to move it to a
containment facility the weather starts
to deteriorate hurricane force wind
sweeps across the water and batter the
coast the hardest kept in a secured
storage Warehouse until it can be moved
the people living in the village nearby
complain of hearing voices and rashes so
itchy that they practically tear their
skin off once the storm passes the
foundation agents load the heart onto a
ship it is to be transported to a
foundation site just across the border
the ocean seems calm and Serene the
foundation ship undocks and begins its
Journey up the coast not too long after
beginning its Journey the ship slowly
drifts off course it is as if the crew
has stopped Manning their posts and the
ship is being controlled by a mind of
its own the foundation ship crashes and
sinks somewhere in the Pacific Ocean
never to be found and most importantly
the heart of
scp-001 doesn't make it to the
foundation site years later a man is
walking along the beach he hears
something it sounds like someone
pounding on a large drum to the rhythm
of a heartbeat the man walks towards the
sound something is drawing him forward
closer and closer to the heartbeat he
walks and walks until the beating stops
he bends down and moves the sand aside
he spots the corner of a mechanical box
sticking out of the white sand the man
digs deeper and pulls out the small box
inside he can see gears whirling and
pistons firing he holds the Box close to
his own heart it seems to speak to him
the man brings the box back to town he
starts to worship the box and soon more
and more people in the area joined the
new religion they cast aside their own
beliefs and focus on the powerful entity
contained within the Box God is not dead
at least not yet but the Prophecies of
the Church of the broken God say that
when the heart is found the God will
reassemble itself once again then The
Unbroken God will destroy all other
false deities until only he remains it's
a quiet evening at Area 11 where the
Pietra Cal fontained spatial
stabilization array is housed a skeleton
crew is working over overnight to ensure
the array is ready for its big test the
following day the foundation has been
working on a particle accelerator that
will contain anomalies with the ability
to manipulate the nature of space-time
the preliminary tests seem promising but
a few last-minute tweaks to the array
are necessary unfortunately it is on
this night in 1982 that marks the
beginning of the end for the SCP
Foundation Dr Kelvin Desmond is
monitoring the array and he notices as
it spools up that there are some minor
power fluctuation in one of the
stabilization arms this problem is not
uncommon due to the vast amounts of
energy being pumped through the array
and the harmonic resonance the machine
gives off which slowly causes the
coupling rings to loosen Calvin Desmond
decides that remounting the
stabilization Rings will be an easy fix
and it's a necessary one he knows that
if the Rings fail during the actual test
the array could end up shut down for
months there is still plenty of time so
Cal of investment grabs his toolbox and
heads down to the array the machine is
still spooling keeping the energy
flowing at a constant low rate there is
no danger at the moment as the inside of
the array is shielded from the radiation
and energy pulsing through the outer
ring but then something unexpected
happens the system's primary generator
begins to fluctuate uncontrollably a
catastrophic failure is imminent Sirens
begin to sound the facility is evacuated
and the Chamber is sealed deep in the
bells of the array Calvin Desmond cannot
hear the evacuation announcement the
humming of the array Echoes through the
chamber dampening all sound from the
outside world the array begins to come
online while Desmond continues to work
on the coupling he has no idea what is
about to happen meanwhile a team of
foundation scientists scrambled to get
the power fluctuations in the main
generator under control as they
frantically work catastrophe strikes
they initiate the power down cycle but
as the generator struggles to keep the
power flow balanced an energy surge
builds up a massive amount of energy is
released all at once causing the main
reactor to explode the entire structure
rocks back and forth and Desmond is
thrown into the side of the array he too
now knows that something is very wrong
and runs for the exit when he reaches
the door he finds that it has been
sealed in a panic Desmond continues
running through the tube to the next
access point this door has been locked
as well he's never been so scared in his
entire life and he shakes uncontrollably
from the adrenaline being dumped into
his muscles The Surge of energy rushes
through the array towards Desmond a
singularity begins to form in the
containment chamber the array is working
just as it should except that there was
never supposed to be a person inside as
the singularity was brought into
existence moments after the singularity
forms the massive pull of its gravity
causes the stabilizer arm that Desmond
had been working on to fail the side of
the array is ripped off and Calvin
Desmond stares into the naked eye of the
singularity everything is silent and
still for a moment then the singularity
collapses in on itself taking the test
chamber and much of the research wing
with it along with Dr Calvin Desmond
sparking wires hanging from the exposed
walls and ceiling where the singularity
rips the main structure away water flows
into the deep hole carved out of the
Earth where the array once stood the
scientists from Area 11 look into the
crater left by the collapsed Singularity
the foundation Administration sends
agents to collect the staff at the site
and document the failings of the project
they conclude that the accident was
caused by human error they ordered the
array to be rebuilt this time using
entirely automated systems to eliminate
the chances of another mishap occurring
several years after the catastrophic
events at Area 11 a new array is
constructed an intelligent system called
netzac is put in charge of overseeing
its functions it is a supercomputer that
is Pro program to follow commands but
can autonomously make decisions in order
to prevent any failures in the system
experiments Begin Again in May of 2006.
the new array soon manifests its first
singularity in the containment chamber
at Area 11 and what happens next will
forever change the foundation and the
Multiverse The Singularity is kept
stable in the array it seems as if the
foundation has succeeded in trapping and
containing spatial anomalies but as they
run more Diagnostics on the anomaly
something unexpected happens The
Singularity begins to grow in size the
point of infinite gravity threatens to
breach containment as it reaches the
boundaries of the array just before
contact the singularity's growth slows
and then stops netsack has made the
split-second calculations and
adjustments necessary to contain the
singularity the artificial intelligence
has saved the facility and the lives of
everyone in it now sitting in the array
is a thick rotating cloud of radio
active gas and dust obscuring the
singularity within as Foundation
scientists work rapidly to fix the array
odd events begin to occur the workers
hear noises that sound like painful
wailing over time the noises evolve into
words and then full sentences they seem
to be originating from The Singularity
using equipment able to penetrate the
thick cloud of radioactive gas the
foundation scientists get a glimpse at
the singularity to their surprise The
Singularity has taken on the shape of a
human the scientists work frantically to
figure out how the singularity could
have formed itself into a humanoid shape
Dr J Barton Ramsey is the first to try
and make contact with the humanoid
within the singularity he finds that the
entity cannot communicate in the
traditional sense the massive
gravitational pull of the singularity
does not allow sound to escape its void
Instead The Entity manipulates gravity
to vibrate the suspension rings of the
array itself and create soundly
being in the singularity Whispers in a
metallic voice created by the vibrating
of the array's Rings and says Johannes
Ramsey Dr Ramsay steps back from the
observation window how do you know my
name he asked the entity the humanoid
within the swirling gas cloud identifies
itself as having the memories of Calvin
Desmond it is not Desmond per se the
being in the singularity is so much more
than one person but it was somehow
created by the accident that had sucked
Calvin Desmond into the singularity
years before the entity seems to switch
between the mind of Desmet and the vast
Infinity of the cosmos The Desmond
entity asks for an overseer from the
foundation to be brought in it has a
proposal for the o5 council when Dr
Ramsey asks why the entity needs to talk
to the overseers it replies that it
wants to offer them away oh the
following day o51 enters the facility
and heads to the observation deck he
looks through the reinforced glass us at
the swirling cloud of radioactive dust
then glances at the monitor to see the
humanoid shape of the singularity within
he presses the microphone button on the
console and addresses The Entity to whom
am I speaking he asks for simplicity's
sake The Entity tells 05-1 to refer to
him as Calvin Desmond 05-1 makes notes
of the events unfolding before him and
then asks about the way out that Calvin
had mentioned the air is still for a
moment then Desmond begins to speak
through the vibration of the structure
once again he informs o5-1 that what the
SCP Foundation is doing by securing and
containing anomalous entities around the
world is like putting a small Band-Aid
on a much bigger wound Desmond wants to
propose a final solution to all of the
foundation's problems o5-1 listens
intently as the entity unravels the
mysteries of where the scps have come
from he explains that the anomalies that
the foundation has worked so hard to
secure contain and protect the human
race from are actually bleeding into
their reality from a vast Multiverse the
only way to stop the manifestation of
anomalies into this universe is to
destroy all other realities the The
Entity that is Kelvin Desmond tells 05-1
that he is able to bring about this
destruction if they release him from the
confines of the array 05-1 is transfixed
by the swirling gas that is promising
him and everyone else on Earth salvation
he shakes his head in disbelief could
this be true 05-1 turns away from the
swirling gas and begins to walk away
from the viewing glass I'll need to
think about what you're saying the
structure begins to shake slightly the
voice of Calvin Desmond reverberates off
of the array a little louder than before
choose quickly overseer although it
won't happen for decades eventually a
catastrophic SCP event will wipe out
life on this planet perhaps not in your
lifetime but it will most certainly
happen within the lifetime of your
children we will talk again soon the
vibration slow and then stop completely
there is an eerie Stillness in the the
observation room as 05-1 walks out the
next day all staff members located at
Area 11 are relocated to other
Foundation sites and given amnestics the
L5 Council meets in a large circular
room with wood paneling and no windows
o5-1 Begins the meeting by telling the
others what Calvin Desmond had described
about the end of the world he pauses for
what seems like an eternity and tells
them of Desmond's offer that he could
prevent the end of the world but at the
cost of destroying an infinite number of
other realities this would mean that all
the humans and creatures of those
realities would be destroyed as well was
murdering countless other beings worth
it to protect their own reality 05-1
begins to shake he hasn't slept or eaten
anything since his talk with Desmond
he's being torn apart from the inside
05-3 stands up and addresses the council
he informs everyone in the room that
independent teams have concluded
Research into what the Calvin Desmond
entity has claimed and they found it to
be true the world really would come to
an end furthermore the research teams
determined that the capabilities of
Desmond would in fact allow him to
dismantle the other realities o5-3
insists that the council must vote to
allow Desmond to destroy the other
realities to ensure that this reality
could be saved they must strike now
before the world is overrun 05-1
continues to Shake while 05-3 breathes
heavily sweat pouring down his temples
the rest of the council shifts their
gazes from side to side it is time for a
vote there are eight eyes to allow
Desmond to destroy all of the realities
and fornays against the plan 05-3 stands
up and walks around the room stopping
behind each nay voter and putting a
bullet in their head he stops at the
last 05-9 who pulls out a gun places it
under her own chin and pulls the trigger
05-13 abstains from the vote in the
measure
the remaining overseers will use the
Calvin Desmond entity to save their
reality at the expense of all others and
they soon head to Area 11 to execute
their plan 05-1 4 and 12 enter the
observation room that looks upon the
swirling radioactive gas around Calvin
Desmond 05-1 orders netsack to begin
powering down the array which will allow
the entity to prove he can do what he
has promised they have pinpointed the
reality that scp-884 came from and the
Shaving mirror itself sits on a table in
another room in the facility 05-3 stands
in the room watching the mirror to see
if anything happens 05-1 asks Calvin
Desmond to eliminate the reality that
the mirror had come from the room Shakes
as the entity uses it to acknowledge the
request moments later the phone rings in
the observation room it is 05-3 he
informs the others that the mirror has
disappeared its reality has been
destroyed and therefore it no longer is
there is a sigh of relief in the room as
the overseers realize that this just
might work 05-1 asks Calvin Desmond to
continue and destroy all the realities
that are bleeding into their own this
time the entire facility begins to Quake
suddenly 05-1 jerks backwards his eyes
wide in confusion and horror his body
seems to be compressing under an unknown
Force 05-1 begins to distort his legs
and arms fold into the core of his body
his head snaps down and all that was
o5-1 is sucked down into a single point
in space before it completely disappears
Calvin Desmond then turns his attention
to the other two overseers in the room
who both seem to collapse into black
holes of their own in the center of
their bodies netsax warning claxen
begins to sound signaling that the
emergency Fail-Safe has been activated
before Calvin Desmond is brought under
control the structural support in the
entire facility vibrates with his words
they are in a voice that sounds strange
strangely similar to o51s your children
are free to live lives that do not end
in horror an end to your Perpetual
struggle an end to Darkness the freedom
to live in the light all traces must be
removed this world must be washed clean
the foundation does not Escape atonement
it is the only way out it had been a
deception the Calvin Desmond entity had
no intention of stopping anomalies from
infiltrating this world it wanted to
remove all traces of the anomalous from
all universes including this one and
that meant destroying the overseers and
the foundation itself their destruction
would serve as an atonement for the pain
and suffering they had caused in their
quest to secure and contain the
anomalous Calvin had to lie to the
overseers about the real plan since he
knew they'd never sacrifice themselves
and the foundation even if it meant an
end to the anomalies plaguing our world
now though with the overseers out of the
way the Calvin Desmond entity is free to
move forward with its plan and Purge all
realities of any trace of the anomalous
but just then netsax failsafes kick in
and the petrachal fountain spatial
stabilization array subdues the entity's
abilities Desmet is once again contained
05-3 burst through the door and into the
observation room he stands before the
shattered glass of the window that looks
into the array 053 asks netsack how long
the containment array can hold Calvin
Desmet the computer's voice fades in and
out but says given current conditions
119 days six hours and 47 minutes
05-3 size he tells netzac to make a node
in the SCP database that the Calvin
Desmond entity will now be known as
scp-001 then to make dozens of other
randomly generated entries and label
them as
scp-001 as well he knows that they will
need to keep the true nature of what
this entity can do with secret 05-3
walks out of the room under his breath
he speaks to himself they'll say that
I'll know the one true God when I see it
and to give that God everything it wants
because that's the only thing that
matters tonight it appears God wants to
talk to me Calvin Lucien stands at the
end of a Dusty table in an abandoned
warehouse in the shadows across from him
sits several hidden figures the
warehouse is falling apart but is
suitable for the meeting Calvin as
requested with the heads of the chaos
Insurgency he has completed numerous
missions for the organization and each
one has been successful now he is
proposing one final mission Calvin
Lucien takes a tattered Journal out of
his bag and slides it across the table
to the figure sitting in the shadows
it's a journal with details on the
habits of each of the 13 Foundation
overseers he says there is silence from
the other end of the table a hand
reaches out and grabs the journal the
pages begin to turn the new models
indicate an anomalous catastrophe is
imminent not even the foundation can
stop it the only way to save the world
is to kill the overseers there are
Whispers from across the table as Calvin
continues the proliferation of anomalies
in the world are the fault of the
overseers they have been meddling with
reality the business continues as usual
we might not make it out of the 2020s we
need to act now the whispering from the
Shadows resumes this time with what
seems to be a little more urgency one of
the voices asked the question on
everyone's mind how do you plan to kill
the obesers they have a deal with death
they are Immortal Calvin smiles and
takes out a small vial from his jacket
pocket with this he says there is a
Silence from the Shadows the journal
slides back across the table and comes
to a stop right in front of Calvin a
deep voice from the shadow says do it
Calvin Lucian gathers his team the code
name given to the group is kill Squad he
informs them that they've been cleared
to take out the overseers it will be the
most dangerous Mission they've ever been
on and even if successful they probably
won't make it out of the line but the
team is loyal they set out to confront
the 13th overseer this has to be their
first stop because without eliminating
05-13 nothing else will matter it is
this overseer who has a deal with death
a deal that protects all the foundation
overseers from dying if that deal can be
broken then Calvin Lucien and his team
will have a shot at eradicating the
other overseers if the deal with death
cannot be broken All Is Lost the team
boards a shift at the tip of South
America and sails towards the Frozen
Waters of Antarctica the kill Squad is
made up of Calvin and three others they
sit in the galley preparing for the
mission ahead Anthony Wright is a
battle-harden soldier who sits at one
end of the table his face is covered
with scars no one can remember when he
first joined the Insurgency because it
was so long ago next to him is Olivia
Torres she is an anarchist who was
recruited into the Insurgency after she
was liberated from a foundation site
during a raid Adam Ivanov sits staring
into his computer screen he is testing
different gadgets that might be of use
on the mission he pushes his glasses up
the bridge of his nose and Strikes the
enter key a long line of code begins to
scroll across the screen a siren begins
to sound informing the crew to make
their way to the main deck when they
surface from the bowels of the ship they
see something in the distance it is a
giant black Tower rising from the depths
of the ocean like an evil Iceberg waves
crash over the side of the railings
drenching the deck and crew with frigid
water Calvin looks at the jagged rocks
along the shore of the tower there is no
way to safely dock there is only one way
onto the island they know what needs to
be done Anthony waits for the next wave
then opens the throttle to full the ship
is carried towards the island on the
crest of the wave the hull is impaled on
the Rocks surrounding the tower sending
everything flowing towards the front of
the boat see that wasn't so bad Calvin
says to his team as he bandages a gash
on his hand knowing what lays ahead
Calvin orders his team to wait on the
ship while he makes his own deal with
death he enters the dark structure and
is greeted by a corpse the corpse speaks
to him ejecting dust from its lungs with
every word its breath smells like
decaying flesh death has inhabited the
body of Dr Felix Carter the 13th
overseer Calvin is prepared though
thanks to the notes in the journal he
possesses without hesitating he takes
out a small bottle of liquid from his
pocket and lunges at the corpse he grabs
it by the neck tilts the head back and
pours liquid down what is left of the
throat to Felix Carter the corpse
reanimates into the living Dr Carter
death has been removed from his body by
liquid from the Fountain of Youth that
Calvin had acquired on a previous raid
on a foundation site seeing that Dr
Carter is now alive Calvin takes out his
pistol and shoots the doctor twice
killing him Calvin picks up the body and
throws it into a bottomless pit at the
base of the tower Dr Felix Carter's body
disappears from sight the overseers deal
with death is now broken they are
vulnerable and can be killed at last
Calvin smiles and begins to turn away
from the pit when he comes face to face
with death she stands with her head [ __ ]
to the side looking at Calvin so it is
you who has broken the overseers deal
with me Calvin Lucian Calvin takes a
step back why didn't she stop him from
killing Felix Carter something Fester is
at the heart of the council death says
something that will not die I thought
that perhaps if I had a seat at their
table I could find it make it die but I
couldn't there are things in this world
Beyond even my reach Calvin Lucian with
that parting thought death vanishes the
kill Squad contacts the Insurgency for
an Evac and then makes their way to
Japan where 05-12 also known as the
accountant has been working out of Tokyo
he is so proficient in mathematics and
probability that he can actually predict
the future everything about the
accountant's life down to the number of
breaths and steps he takes each day is
predetermined based on his own
statistical models this poses a problem
for Calvin and his team if the
accountant can see them coming then how
can they possibly kill him that night
the accountant steps out of his car he
looks to the left and spots Adam he has
already predicted this man has hostile
intentions the accountant walks directly
towards Adam and before he can react
throws the kill Squad member to the
ground then he turns slightly and
adjusts his watch sending a glare
directly into the window where Anthony
has the accountant in his sights of his
sniper rifle Anthony fires but misses
due to being blinded by the glare the
accountant is surprised that he just
barely had time to avoid being shot
normally he would be several steps ahead
of anyone trying to kill him he turns
his head and watches as Olivia helps
Adam up and they run down a nearby alley
the accountant pursues them and Corners
to kill Squad members in the alley he
pulls a gun to shoot at him but Olivia
tackles Adam behind a dumpster as the
bullet hits the wall directly behind
where Adam was standing the accountant
can't believe that he missed and that he
was almost tricked into being captured
by the Insurgency team he senses
uncertainty in his assailant's actions
and runs away unable to predict exactly
what they are planning to do the
accountant climbs the stairs to a subway
station and Boards the last car of the
train it is empty except for one man
Calvin Lucian the accountant is
dumbfounded how are you here he screams
I should have seen this coming Calvin
stands up he uses his thumb to flip a
coin into the air on the way down he
grabs it and smacks it on the back of
his opposing hand Calvin Smiles the team
has been making their decisions based on
the flip of a coin which introduced
Randomness into their actions that even
this super Advanced mathematician could
not account for tell me where 05-11 is
demands Calvin the accountant pauses
then shakes his head no if he's going to
die either way then why give any
information to the kill Squad Calvin
flips the coin up in the air catches it
and looks at it the coin is face up
Calvin lifts his pistol and shoots the
accountant in the head a few nights
later Olivia stands on a balcony outside
of an Art Exhibit overlooking the city
of Seattle Anthony walks up behind her
and tells her that the foundation is
defeated but Olivia doesn't understand
how we broke the overseers deal with
death and killed the accountant there's
nothing more to do we can go back to our
normal lives he tells her Olivia is
skeptical though what about the 11th
overseer and his ability to Olivia's
eyes suddenly go wide she pulls out a
knife and stabs it into Anthony's Heart
the world around her begins to distort
and fall apart it was a false reality
created by 05-11 better known as the
liar Olivia wakes up up next to Adam in
a hotel room she sits up in a bed and
rubs her eyes what a weird dream she
thinks then she realizes it wasn't a
dream she shakes at him away neither of
them have any idea how they ended up
here but they know it must be the doing
of the liar they had planned for this
though with Calvin having created a
contingency plan they pull out a laptop
and log in to view the classified
information Calvin left for them Olivia
begins to type but stops halfway through
her password and looks up from the
screen Olivia pulls out the gun that
rests under her pillow and shoots at him
the false reality created by the liar
falls apart around her Olivia comes out
of the previous lie and is sitting
across the table from Calvin she
immediately draws her pistol and points
it at kelvin's head is it really him or
just another one of the Liars games
Calvin tries to talk Olivia down and she
looks around the room for
inconsistencies that might tip her off
that this is another lie but doesn't
find any Olivia begins to relax she
tells Calvin that the liar is trying to
get something from her maybe the journal
can tell them what he is looking for as
long as she still has it Olivia nods her
head and holds out her wrist where a
subdermal chip with a copy of the
journal on it has been placed Calvin
looks at her wrist the world around them
begins to dissipate as Calvin morphs
into the liar Olivia wakes up in a
hospital where she is hooked up to an IV
sitting across from her is a former
Insurgency agent Named Sam Beal he
explains to her that he is the liar he
was forced into becoming a monster by
the foundation they had manipulated him
but now he is tired of running and can't
do it anymore she's free to go Olivia
hesitantly unhooks herself from the IV
she walks out of the hospital room and
proceeds down a fluorescent lit hallway
as she walks away she hears a gunshot
from the hospital room as Olivia's in
the hospital Calvin and Adam walked
through a dense forest they are
searching for 05-10 the journal
indicates that the 10th overseers
identity within the foundation is the
archivist in the middle of the clearing
are two saplings standing side by side
the void between the sapling shimmers
Calvin walks through the portal and the
space begins to warp and twist around
him his vision finally comes back into
focus and Calvin finds himself in
another world
Adam enters the World Behind Calvin
practically knocking him over as he
enters through the portal this is The
Wanderers library but it doesn't look
anything like they expected instead of
rows of books the library is filled with
computer mainframes humming with the
collected knowledge of how to contain
anomalies a critical backup as the two
look intently at the strange machines a
figure in a silver robe suddenly steps
out of the darkness it's tall and thin
and though its hood is pulled down so
they can't see its face they can see
that its hands are covered in scales
that have a slight Emerald tint it is
one of the Librarians Calvin tells the
librarian that they are seeking the
archivist but the librarian tells them
that the archivist is no longer in the
library she has broken her pact with the
serpent and eaten fruit from The
Forbidden trees if they want to see her
though the librarian can take them to
her
Calvin and Adam follow the librarian
down a long staircase passing by
countless doors filled with books
Scrolls works of art an entire universe
of knowledge eventually they reached the
bottom of the stairs where there stands
a giant set of brass doors Beyond the
Door the librarian explains is the
source of all knowledge before Calvin
and Adam pass through the doors though
Calvin turns to the librarian before we
go in I'd like to make a withdrawal he
says the librarian nods and pulls out a
silver tube out of its row it hands the
tube to Adam and he looks it over in his
hands he looks up to ask what this is
but the librarian has vanished the door
then opens and the two-step through
Calvin and Adam feel as if they walk
through the same kind of portal that
brought them to the library and find
that they have walked into a lush Green
Valley with two trees sitting underneath
one of them is a woman in a white dress
she is reading a book and eating a piece
of fruit are you the archivist Calvin
asks the woman nods yes and that's all
the confirmation Calvin needs he raises
his pistol and fires but the bullet
passes right through the archivist as if
she wasn't there
do you read the archivist asks Calvin
seemingly not phased by his attempts to
shoot her I haven't had much time
recently Calvin replied the archivist
explains that she's read every book in
the library the collected knowledge of
the universe is in the books even one on
how to allow bullets to pass through
your body she came here to find the
secret to immortality it's her job to
document everything that happens in the
world and she can't do that if she's
dead she explains that she figured out
that the fruit that the serpent forbade
everyone to eat was an actual fruit but
the knowledge contained in the library
by having read every book she has
consumed the fruit she no longer needs
the serpent because she was the serpent
the archivist falls to the ground and
begins to ride around contorting her
body as it starts to change she begins
to elongate as her limbs seemingly
disappear the next thing Calvin and Adam
know their face to face with a giant
Calvin Dodges as the serpent lunges at
him and Adam stands in the doorway
firing at the snake with his pistol but
just like with the archivists human form
the bullets have no effect the serpent
coils around Calvin and begins to choke
the life from him as Adam can only watch
helpless
Calvin cries out with his last breath
him
Adam takes the tube that was given to
him by the librarian and opens the cap a
long heavy spear slides out that looks
much too large to have ever fit inside
he drops the tube to the ground and
watches in amazement as it starts to
transform turning into what looks like a
large Harpoon Gun Adam knows what to do
and places the giant spear into the gun
and points it at the serpent
you can't kill me the giant snake sense
I've eaten from the Tree of Life
Adam pulls the trigger and the huge
spear flies through the air striking the
serpent in the head Adam runs to Calvin
and helps him to his feet they turn to
look at the snake but instead of the
menacing creature it's the archivist
once again pinned against the tree she
once sat under the spear sticking out of
her skull
as the two stand looking at the
archivist a tall hooded humanoid figure
steps out from behind the tree it looks
similar to The Librarian except its robe
is a greenish color and it wears long
black gloves the creature pulls the
spear out of the archivist whose body
slumps to the ground and hands the spear
to Calvin who are you Calvin asks but
his question is ignored after a moment
the figure finally speaks that spear
you'll now hold is called the Spear of
the non-believer it is an ancient weapon
used to kill Gods it is odd that someone
in this realm gave you the spear even
with it I'm not sure you will be able to
complete your quest Calvin Lucian but we
shall see there is a sudden flash of
light and Calvin and Adam find
themselves transported back to the
forest they had entered The Wanderers
library from a week later Calvin and
Anthony Tracked Down 05-9 who in the
council is known as The Outsider she
isn't hard to find and it seems as if
she actually wanted to be found they
find her sitting outside of her burnt
down family home the journal had listed
this as her address but Calvin doubted
that she would be here and most he hoped
to find a clue to her whereabouts but
here she was sitting in the ashes of her
home without turning around the outsider
began speaking the council just used me
you know she says they took away my
academic career my friends and my life
they made me conduct research for them
that compromised everything I stood for
and now here I am with nothing The
Outsider lets out a sigh she asked
Calvin if he's afraid of death Calvin
shakes his head and responds Now The
Outsider slumps forward and Calvin walks
around to face her she is covered in
blood her eyes move to look up at Calvin
you're lying she says as she dies from
self-inflicted wounds Calvin and Anthony
cross 05-9 off the list and head back to
the car as they walk Anthony says what's
been on everyone's Minds the last few
days the easy part is done will only get
harder from here we know 05-8 is in his
castle I'm sure we'll get in but I'm not
sure if we'll make it out alive I know
replies Calvin but if we're going to
save the world we must eliminate the
rest of the overseers even if it means
sacrificing our own lives they get in
the car and drive off into the blood red
sunset to pick up the rest of the kill
squad team before their next mission
Calvin Lucian leads the kill squad team
through the mud and freezing rain in
front of them looms The Fortress of
Baron Lehman hotly the eighth overseer
the team has already been through a lot
from breaking the overseer council's
deal with death by eliminating 05-13 to
using the Spear of the non-believer to
kill the Godlike archivist 05-10 the
hunting of overseers has taken a toll on
the kill Squad 05-12 almost killed Adam
and Olivia was stuck in what seemed like
an endless mind game with 05-11 the
first five overseers were eliminated but
the words that the ninth overseer spoke
to Calvin Lucien before she died still
run through his mind are you afraid of
death now the kill Squad is about to
infiltrate one of the most heavily
guarded facilities in the world to
eliminate the eighth overseer upon
reaching the castle the team is
surprised to find the structure is in
ruin no one is supposed to know the
location of o5-8 though the Fortress was
supposed to be practically impregnable
they stormed the castle of o5-8 all the
same the journal Calvin possesses that
contains information about the members
of the SCP foundation's powerful o5
Council identifies him as a former
industrialist named Baron Lehman Hodley
with his vast wealth holdy funded the
foundation at the start and was
considered the unofficial leader of the
council in its early days with immense
control over the actions of the
organization the kill Squad makes their
way through the dimly lit hallways of
the castle as they turn the corner they
are surprised to find the charred
remains of Baron Lehman hodley's
bodyguard it seems that someone or
something has gotten too hardly before
they could the team makes their way to
the main chamber and breaches the door
laying by a still-lit fireplace is 05-8
the kill Squad scans the room to make
sure the killer isn't still in there
with them Adam walks over to the body
and examines it he quickly realizes that
holdley hasn't been murdered at all he
sees that Baron hoadley's body has been
drastically modified using anomalous
technology the overseer used his
immortality to modify almost every part
of his body to make himself stronger
unfortunately for Baron hoadley when the
overseers deal with death was broken by
Calvin the modifications to his body
slowly tore him apart his regular body
could no longer support all the
modifications and what once made him
practically Invincible became the very
thing that destroyed him the team leaves
the castle and crosses 05-8 off their
list on their way out Adam pulls Calvin
aside he has the feeling that Anthony
has hasn't been completely honest with
the rest of the team he had the feeling
that Anthony was hiding something from
them Calvin had similar thoughts
recently he pushes Anthony for more
information about his past and Anthony
reveals that he's over 100 years old the
vial of water from the Fountain of Youth
that Calvin has was not the only one
early in his career with the Insurgency
he had confiscated other vials from a
foundation site his Squad drank the
water and it extended their lives he
asks Calvin on what he plans on doing
with his water from the fountain I'm
going to destroy it Calvin tells him
Anthony agrees with his plan once you
drink from the Fountain of Youth you may
extend your life but a part of you dies
at the same time vibrancy of the senses
disappears leading to a seemingly
shallow life if Anthony could go back
and do it again he never would have
drank the water Calvin receives Intel
from the Insurgency that the seventh
overseer is in a small town in Cambodia
the kill Squad makes their way to the
village and surveys the area hoping to
get a glimpse at the overseer who is
codenamed Green as the team conducts
reconnaissance Anthony tells them that
he thinks the mission is a setup it is
too remote and there are so many unknown
variables but Calvin is convinced that
this might be their only chance to kill
green since green arrived in the area
there has been non-stop chaos she has
destabilized the local governments and
now the area is in an all-out War the
team weaves through narrow passageways
between houses and buildings trying to
make their way to the central compound
where green is located suddenly a mob
starts to form they are getting closer
and closer to the team in a quick
decision to avoid being seen Calvin
orders everyone into a nearby building
before Anthony can follow the mob rounds
the corner they spot Anthony and he's
forced to flee Calvin Olivia and Adam
watch as the mob chases after Anthony
but they have to keep moving Calvin
knows that Anthony can take care of him
self they're too close to their goal to
stop now Calvin slowly opens the front
door of the house they are hiding in and
peers out the coast looks clear so he
signals Olivia and Adam to follow him
before they can step out into the street
a gas canister enters through a cracked
doorway the room fills with sleeping gas
and the team passes out when they are
awake they are tied up in a large room
with marble vaulted ceilings 05-7 is
standing in front of Calvin she smiles
wickedly while holding a knife she
compliments Calvin on what he and his
team have been able to do so far no one
believed they could pull off even a
fraction of what they have but now she
has an offer for Calvin she points
towards Adam and Olivia and tells Calvin
he must choose one of them to die if he
doesn't she'll kill the leader of the
rioters and plunge another part of the
country into chaos screw you is Calvin's
response very well utter's great have it
your way she assassinates the leader
being held in her compound then turns
back to Calvin she now threatens to
torture his team until Calvin makes a
choice of who to kill green slashes
Adam's cheek with her knife as Calvin
screams for green to leave his team
alone and torture him instead green Just
Smiles I'm going to enjoy killing your
friends while you watch as you have
killed so many of my overseers on the
council she reaches up in the air with a
knife above Adam's head before she can
plunge the knife through his skull a
bullet passes through her hand causing
her to drop the knife Anthony kneels on
a rooftop across the courtyard smoking
sniper rifles still pointed at Green who
runs Calvin uses the drop knife to cut
his ropes and chases after green he
follows her to the roof where he watches
as she boards a helicopter the aircraft
lifts off as Anthony Fires at it from
his original position but does no
serious damage in the plaza below the
mob that has separated the team earlier
becomes restless there is complete chaos
and someone fires a rocket at the
helicopter the rocket hits the tail of
the aircraft sending it crashing into
the plaza full of rioters below as the
crowd flees from the sea Calvin makes
his way towards the wreckage and reaches
it at the same time Anthony does Calvin
looks at him smiles and thanks him for
saving his life Anthony smiles back but
before he can say anything a gunshot
rings out and a bullet rips through his
neck Calvin turns to see where it came
from and is horrified to see the burning
body of 05-7 her skin has been charred
black but in her burnt hand she holds a
gun what's left of her lips curl back in
a Sinister grin as she fires again and
hits Anthony in the chest he falls to
the ground Calvin runs to him and pulls
out his gun to shoot 05-7 but she is
already dead Calvin holds his dying
teammate as blood pours out of his neck
and chest but Calvin can stop this he
pulls out the vial of water from the
fountain no when says Anthony I have
lived long enough thank you my friend I
will see you in whatever lies Beyond
this life Anthony's chess Rises then
Falls it does not rise again Olivia and
Adam Round the Corner to see Calvin
holding the lifeless body of their
teammate tears flowing from his eyes the
team holds a small ceremony and burial
for Anthony but are only halfway through
their mission and can't stop now they
fly back to the United States where an
undercover Insurgency agent named
Kowalski informs them that 05-6 is
already aware thereafter him this
overseer is codenamed the American
because he has the power of the entire
U.S military at his fingertips the kill
Squad Scouts the base where the American
is located Kowalski warns them of a
crate that was recently brought to the
base from site 19. the Americans showed
great interest in whatever was in the
container the group sets up a camp on a
hill overlooking the base as the sun
slowly Rises the next day the kill Squad
is spotted by a drone and forced to hop
in their Jeep and try to run they make
their way down the hill finding
themselves in the valley below with no
clear exit in front of them lands a
helicopter as Humvees Roar into the
canyon behind them the team is
surrounded a Jeep pulls up an 05-6 steps
out he introduces himself as Rufus King
member of the overseer Council but an
American citizen first and foremost all
he really wants is to protect the
country he loves thanks to you I've lost
my immortality and can no longer
effectively protect the United States
anymore the American says to Calvin but
I am willing to make a deal your freedom
for the Spear of the non-believer
rumahaza that you have the spear in your
possession and you used it to kill the
archives you give me the spear I will
let you go no replies Calvin I will
never give an overseer the means to
cause more destruction the spear stays
with us very well the American says with
a frown then I suppose my only other
option is to take it from you but not
without giving you a fair chance run
Calvin Lucian run as fast as you can ah
will be coming for you the American
turns and walks towards the container
from site 19 which is being lowered from
a helicopter hovering above them Calvin
Sprints back to the jeep with the other
members of his team as they drive away
they hear a horrible guttural Screech
from whatever was inside the container
after a few moments the Army begins to
pursue them out in front of the military
force is 05-6 writing
scp-682 he is using a black whip to urge
the creature forward and they're gaining
on the kill Squad fast a row of vehicles
pulls up beside the American and
scp-682 then something strange happens a
man appears in front of the oncoming
forces led by the American the the man's
skin bulges and seems to be moving from
within the skin of the man sloughs from
his body the infection that is scp-610
erupts out of him and onto the soldiers
in the nearby Jeep scp-610 begins to
infect and consume everyone around it
suddenly there are thousands of
instances of scp-610 coming from the
Mountainside flooding into the valley
they close in and around the Army and
05-6 the American begins fighting off
the flesh-eating creatures from the back
of scp-682 but he becomes overwhelmed he
can no longer focus on pursuing Calvin
and his team from the back of the Jeep
Olivia pulls out her rifle she aims and
fires the bullet hits the American in
the chest he is flung off the back of
scp-682 and engulfed in a sea of scp-610
creatures the kill Squad continues to
drive trying to put as much distance
between themselves and the scp-610
infestation as Paul possible but then
Calvin suddenly Slams on the Brank
standing in front of them is a man in a
black suit and bow tie he introduces
himself as Blackbird the fifth overseer
according to the journal his actual name
is Mortimer J Denning Von krukniker he
stands in front of the jeep with a
menacing grin you have been causing a
lot of trouble he says looking at Calvin
Olivia swings her gun around oh please
my dear that won't help you Von
crockmekar says he pulls out a knife and
stabs himself through the neck he falls
to the ground apparently dead there is a
gust of wind a whiff of ozone and an
identical copy and still very much alive
on cocknicker lands next to his own dead
body see what I mean he says Olivia
lowers her rifle come with me I have
something to show you the Blackbird
beckons seeing no other option Calvin
olivian Adam exit the Jeep and followed
the Blackbird as they walk the World
changes around them the desert mountains
Fade Away into Blackness and find
themselves in the near apocalyptic
London oh it's good to be how the
Blackbird says as they emerge onto a
cobblestone street you cannot stop the
overseas plans however I can give you an
alternative let's see if any of you will
take it in front of each kill Squad
member appears adore they have an
uncontrollable urge to open their
respective door and walk through the
Blackbird stands smiling as he watches
Calvin Olivia and Adam enter each of
their portals Adam enters his door and
looks around he is in Portland his
parents walk into the room in this
universe his family has been granted
Asylum Adam never has to interact with
any scps or the foundation he is free to
live a normal life from the kitchen
comes Calvin wearing an apron he is
holding a steaming pot Adam lock size
with Calvin who Smiles at him the
Blackbird Whispers into Adam's ear in
this reality both of your parents and
siblings are still alive also the man
you love loves you back you and Calvin
could be married if you stayed here
wouldn't that be nice Olivia enters her
door she is on the deck of a yacht and
the bow sits an easel with art supplies
the man that Olivia once loved walks
across the deck towards her the
Blackbird looms over her in this reality
you didn't accidentally kill him this
could be your happily ever after
wouldn't that be nice Calvin steps
through his door he is in a grassy
clearing near a lake the Blackbird
hisses in Calvin's ear I'm giving you
the opportunity to save your mother this
time Calvin you would just a scared
little boy but in this reality you can
be prey you can actually save your
mother from her faith no Calvin screams
this is isn't real the Blackbird cackles
Calvin looks away from the lake and
towards the tree line hidden in the
shadows he can just barely make out a
hooded figure Calvin walks towards it
the Blackbird follows he is screaming at
the person in the tree line I was only
trying to help the hooded figure reaches
out and hands Calvin a metal tube he
opens it to find a set of eyeglasses
inside Calvin puts them on and turns to
look at the Blackbird he steps back in
horror the glasses have revealed the
true form of the Blackbird he is a
winged pseudo-avian monstrosity full of
Rage the mysterious hooded figure
directs Calvin to open the tube again
inside is an interdimensional fishing
line made by DR wondertainment and a
white wiffle ball bat Calvin grabs the
fishing line and wraps it around
05-5's lag the Blackbird flies into the
air trying to get away from Calvin but
Calvin wraps the other end of the
fishing line around his arm the
Blackbird begins to jump from Dimension
to dimension trying to get rid of Calvin
they appear on the deck of scp-455 in
site 19 where scp-682 walks freely in
the dead world of scp-2935 every time
they stop in a new dimension Calvin
takes the opportunity to attack the
blackbird with the bad and it seems that
he is slowly weakening the monster they
finally land at the bottom of a deep
well foundation containment site where
the dark body that is
scp-001 is contained standing in front
of the containment field is Alison Cho
The Black Queen whose sole mission is to
destroy the foundation you cries the
Blackbird you are the one who's been
helped being Lucian The Black Queen nods
her head yes I have been helping Calvin
Lucien to eliminate you and the other
overseers the foundation Must Fall you
want nothing you cannot stop me I am the
black king
screams05-5 Alison chau's size she
pushes a button on the panel next to her
shutting down the array containing the
dark body out of the cloud of dust
appears
scp-001 a massive black creature who
seemed to absorb all light no stop
shrieks the Blackbird
scp-001 does not move but the room
begins to shake the Blackbird continues
to scream as his body folds in on itself
until he is reduced to a single
superheated point and then blinks out of
existence Allison Chao then reactivates
the containment array ceiling zero zero
one away once again I will return you to
your reality along with your friends
says the black queen but perhaps our
path shall cross again Calvin Lucian
there is a bright flash of light and
Calvin finds himself on a private jet
sitting next to Olivia and Adam they are
all shaken but the Blackbird is dead
05-5 has been eliminated the three
members of the team sit silently still
pondering What Might Have Been if they
stayed in the alternate realities
suddenly the phone on the plane begins
to ring breaking the silence Calvin
picks it up on the other line is the
fourth overseer he has contacted Calvin
to discuss surrendering to the
Insurgency unfortunately things do not
always go planned Calvin Lucian is about
to make the most difficult and dangerous
decision of his life
Aaron Siegel better known to Foundation
members as 05-1
descends into the abyss of a Deep Well
site he exits the elevator and peers
into the optical scanner to unlock the
reinforced door inside the room is
mobile task force tau5 samsara Aaron
Siegel refers to these Immortal cyborg
clones created from the Flesh of a dead
God as his red right hand your mission
is to eliminate the trader 05-4 and to
find the insurgents who have been
killing the members of the overseer
Council the cyborg stand at attention
now Aaron Siegel screams the soldiers of
the red right hand March out the door to
start their mission Aaron Siegel pauses
for a moment and then slams his fist
against the wall in frustration he has
lost nine overseers to Calvin Lucien and
his kill squad team they have been
somehow overcoming the odds each time
and eliminating each overseer they track
down it wasn't supposed stand this way
Aaron Siegel vows to kill them all
Calvin Lucien meanwhile sits on a
private jet with Adam and Olivia he had
just hung up the phone after a
conversation with 05-4 the overseer
known as the Ambassador wants to
surrender to the Insurgency there's a
good chance this is a trap but Calvin
has decided to meet with the Ambassador
all the same Calvin drops off Adam and
Olivia at an Insurgency base they still
haven't fully recovered from the
previous Mission with 05-5 known as the
Blackbird before leaving though Calvin
meets with an Insurgency agent named
Sylvester Sloan who is going to join him
as support Calvin says goodbye to Adam
and Olivia then leaves with Sloan to
meet The Ambassador in South Africa
after landing at Johannesburg airport
Calvin and Sloan disembark and are led
to a conference room where the
Ambassador sits waiting for them Calvin
and Sloane sit across from 05-4 to
discuss his surrender the council is in
shambles says the Ambassador everything
is falling apart I want to offer my
services and information to the
Insurgency in exchange for protection
from 05-1 is lost his mind Galvin agrees
to the terms and prepares for extraction
but as they get up from the table
gunshots can be heard from down the hall
the ambassador's eyes open wide in
Terror it's too late he whispers Calvin
and Sloan grabbed the Ambassador who is
Frozen in fear and exit the conference
room they make their way towards their
plane but the gunshots are getting
closer Calvin looks over his shoulder to
see some sorrow pursuing them through
the terminal Calvin shoves the
Ambassador behind a table as bullets
whiz overhead Calvin and Sloan returned
fire but their volley doesn't seem to
slow down the Assassins Calvin and Sloan
pulled the ambassador to his feet and
they burst through an emergency exit
onto the sun-baked tarmac where they
make a Mad Dash for the plane from
behind them a bullet rips through the
chest of Sloan the red right hand has
caught up but Calvin continues to drag
the ambassador to plane they are almost
there suddenly a metallic child's Voice
blars through the airport's external
speakers the child's voice says I want
Calvin Lucian alive I have business to
settle with him the red right hand
soldiers tackle Calvin and the
ambassador to the ground when they are
just feet away from the plane kill the
traitor the child's voice says and
Calvin can only watch helplessly as the
Ambassador is violently murdered one of
the agents turns towards Calvin and
slams his fist into Calvin's face
causing him to black out Calvin awakes
in a dark room he is unsure how much
time has passed the only light in the
room comes from a screen on the wall in
the middle of the screen is a rotating
red SCP Foundation seal a voice from a
speaker speaks hello Calvin Lucian my
name is the kid I am the third overseer
you have killed all my friends and now I
will kill all of yours the door to the
room opens Calvin leans through the
doorway there is a long dimly lit
hallway the kid orders him to proceed so
they can meet face to face as Calvin
walks the kids voice Echoes down the
hallway there once was another 05-3 he
built incredible machines even one that
could see into the future but
unfortunately for him he did not have
the passion required to be an overseer
that was when I was born I was chosen by
the other overseers to have my spinal
cord severed in a way that gave me the
ability of the All-Seeing Eye I now
watch everything all of the time I have
perfect reasoning perfect awareness and
perfect understanding Calvin gets to the
end of the corridor which opens up into
a large chamber tied up in the middle of
the room are Olivia and Adam Calvin runs
to his friends and crouches down next to
them a mechanical suit stands on a
platform looking down at Calvin Olivia
and Adam Calvin realizes the kid must be
contained inside I now sentence you all
to death the mechanical suit says as the
red right hand steps out of the shadows
and slowly walks towards the remaining
members of the kill Squad suddenly
there's a flash of light and the black
queen appears stop what are you doing
shrieks the kid the black queen hands
Calvin the interdimensional rod and reel
he used to defeat the Blackbird Calvin
casts the rod from out of the terror in
space comes a massive multi-armed
creature known as maladramigion the red
right hand engages the monster trying to
force it back into its Dimension but the
monster is too powerful it grabs the
cyborg clones and pulls them through the
tear in reality as samsara battles the
maladramikion Calvin freeze Olivia and
Adam they make a run for the door but as
they flee one of the walls opens up to
reveal a turret the gun fires and a
bullet hits Olivia directly in the head
killing her instantly no yells Calvin
before Calvin can push Adam out of the
way a second bullet from the turret
launches itself in Adam's back Calvin
and Adam slide across the floor the kid
in his mechanical suit jumps down from
the platform above I'm going to kill you
now Calvin Lucian he says in his
mechanical voice there is another flash
of light Calvin watches in front of him
as the Spear of the non-believer
manifests itself before his eyes Calvin
grabbed the spear and shoves it into the
kid's machine body it easily penetrates
the armor and pins him to the wall
Calvin walks up to the exoskeleton and
tears off the outer plating revealing a
tank full of fluid within which floats a
malformed human fetus as Calvin finally
looks upon the kid's True Form he hears
the sound of mocking mechanical laughter
Calvin breaks the glass and crushes the
kid with his bare hands as Calvin turns
from the now silent robotic body of the
kid the room begins to shame debris
raining down from above Calvin helps
Adam up and puts Olivia's lifeless body
across lost his shoulders while remains
of the kill Squad makes their way out of
the kid's Lair outside of the foundation
side where they were being held Calvin
helps Adam lie down on the ground before
gently setting Olivia's body next to him
Adam grimaces as blood pours out at the
wound in his back Calvin reaches into
his pocket and pulls out the vial of
water from the Fountain of the youth
there are only a couple of drops left
which he pours into Adam's mouth Adam
looks up at Calvin tears filling his
eyes he whispers I love you before he
passes out from the pain the wound in
his back begins to heal instantly and
Calvin calls an Insurgency Evac team to
come pick up Adam with Adam safe Calvin
picks up Olivia and walks alone towards
a truck in the lot outside of the
foundation site he needs to finish this
once and for all he will kill the last
two overseers or he will die trying 05-1
Aaron Siegel arrives at where the Tigris
and Euphrates rivers meet the garden of
Eden he is in a frenzy due to the
assassinations of all the other
overseers besides himself and the
Nazarene and nothing will stop him as he
approaches the gate to the Garden of
Eden though he is stopped by the
guardian of the garden a massive
powerful anomalous entity with a flaming
sword but Aaron Siegel has no time or
patience for anything to get in his way
even something as powerful as the gate
Guardian the guardian swings his burning
sword at Adam who rolls out of the way
and in a Flash takes out a Scranton
reality anchor he slams The Anchor into
the ground which causes the world to
Shimmer and ripple around him he watches
as the Flames from the gate Guardian
Sword seem to absorb back into its body
before it shrinks down looking to fold
in on itself until all that is left is a
charred skeleton with the guardian
defeated Aaron Sprints into the garden
he searches the garden for o5-2 but
can't find her anywhere he finally comes
to the tree of life and that's where he
finds her laying at the base of the tree
in a pool of blood is the Nazarene she
has taken her own life this is her
anomalous power though she has died many
times before yet death always spared her
and brought her back but somehow he
knows this time is final Aaron drops to
his knees and screams in frustration for
all the power Aaron Siegel possesses
there's nothing he can do now he sits
next to the nazarene's body for hours
hoping that she might wake up or that he
will to find that this was all a dream
after sitting next to her cold body for
some time he notices something in her
Snowy White Hand it's a no in it the
Nazarene explains that she was the one
who gave the vials from the fountain to
Calvin Lucian and that she is the one
who made the spear appear before him
that he used to kill the kid she
explained that while she died many times
and death always brought brought her
back each time she felt less and less
like herself less and less like Dr
Sophia line she hoped that maybe if
things ended up like this it would give
Aaron the chance to walk away and live
the life that they might have been able
to have together but she knows deep down
that Aaron's fate is to meet Calvin and
finish things once and for all Aaron
Siegel screams and rage clutching the
node in his hand he tries to summon
death but no one comes Aaron Siegel is
alone he stands up and walks deeper into
the garden he walks until he reaches a
spot where even God's light does not
reach in this desolate land is an impact
crater where Lucifer star of the morning
had fallen in the middle of the crater
lies Lucifer's sword Aaron Siegel
descends into the hole and picks up the
sword he turns and exits the Garden of
Eden Aaron Siegel has only one mission
in life now to kill
Calvin Lucian Calvin reads the final
entry of the journal in it the author
warns that although he hopes the
information contained within the journal
is helpful he hopes the reader does not
try to use it the words written on the
final page are this information will
only lead you to a devastating end
Calvin closes the journal and looks up
at the structure in front of him he has
made it to scythe01 he had left Olivia's
body in a cave nearby promising to her
that he would make this right he now
walks up to the massive doors and places
his hand on the knotted wood the doors
slowly Creak open Calvin pauses for a
moment and looks behind him at the
Setting Sun he enters site-01 where he
knows 05-1 is where Aaron Siegel Waits
inside the main hall Calvin sees a giant
doorway in the shape of the SCP
Foundation seal with artistic depictions
of certain scps that he instinctively
knows are special in some way standing
next to the doorway is a two meter tall
man in what looks to be a futuristic
suit Calvin approaches and asks who this
giant man is he responds that his name
is purpose the red right hand he is the
guardian of o5-1 and None Shall enter
the sanctum until he returns he isn't
Heir ask Calvin no purpose responds he
is and with that he steps aside and lets
Calvin pass through the doorway the
doorway leads into a large room where
screens on the wall flash to life
depicting moments from Calvin's Journey
documenting his entire Quest had he been
in control at all or was this all a
setup to lead him to this moment as he
walks forward he finally sees him
sitting at a table in the middle of the
room is Aaron Siegel Euro 5-1 Calvin
asks Aaron the man responds my name is
Aaron governor masks about the location
of the second overseer the Nazarene but
05-1 doesn't respond without needing any
more information Calvin pulls out his
sidearm and in a Flash fires off five
shots the bullets stopped in the air
inches from Aaron before dissolving in a
flash of light Calvin should have known
it wouldn't be this easy stand up Aaron
Siegel Calvin calls up as he holsters
his gun let's finish it Calvin pulled
the Spear of the non-believer from his
back but Aaron's only response was to
laugh
you don't even know why you're here
Aaron said Calvin calls back I'm here to
kill you because when I do I kill the
foundation because when you're gone the
universe can finally heal you're like me
Calvin Lucian we are both men driven by
our own convictions regardless of the
outcome it would seem Fate has brought
us together now either your convictions
will be broken or you will die says Erin
Siegel he then draws Lucifer's flaming
sword and lunges towards Calvin Lucian
as the two men clash with one another
their Supernatural weapons begin to
destroy the room around them Furniture
is shattered video screens are
obliterated and fire spreads across the
walls Aaron catches Calvin off balance
and swings the Flaming sword across
Calvin's stomach Calvin slides back from
the impact hunching over from the pain
in his midsection he brings his head up
to see Aaron Siegel running towards him
with a flaming sword high in the air
Calvin brings up the spear from his
knees he leans back and launches it
towards Aaron Siegel the spear enters
the final overseer's chest the force
from the throw pinning him against the
wall Aaron Siegel drops Lucifer's sword
it shatters as it hits the ground he
clutches the shaft of the spear
protruding from his sternum with both
hands 05-1 looks at Calvin unbelievingly
you have no idea what you've done it was
never about the overseers Aaron Siegel
says spitting out blood with every word
it was something deeper something worse
Calvin walks slowly towards Aaron Siegel
he stops just in front of his final
enemy this is the way it ends Calvin
says Aaron Siegel manages to whisper one
final word Sofia before his body finally
goes limp Calvin turns to see purpose
standing behind him he's dead Calvin
says half to purpose and half to himself
I kill them after a moment he asks
purpose what he really wants to know
there's a room in this facility where
someone could unmake the foundation
right take me there without any
hesitation purpose leads Calvin back to
the room with depictions of important
scps their purpose opens the door to an
elevator but stops Calvin before he can
get inside I am Duty bound to tell you
purpose says that once you step inside
this elevator there is no going back
there is only one decision to be made
and it is not one that can be unmade I
know Calvin responds it's time before
stepping inside the elevator opens a
door to reveal a room filled with
bookcases and a huge window offering a
beautiful view of the sun setting behind
the mountains on the wall are monitors
depicting the ways he had killed all of
the overseers and in the middle of the
room is a large desk with a computer
Calvin sits down at the desk and the
computer comes to life the computer
prompts him to scan his fingerprint
which it accepts he's logged in the
computer screen displays numerous
locations around the planet and he
quickly recognizes that they are all SCP
Foundation sites then he sees the single
option the computer is giving him
terminate Calvin reaches out with his
finger this is it once he presses this
button the SCP Foundation will be no
more his finger is millimeters from the
button when the phone rings Calvin
hadn't even noticed that there was a
phone on the desk Calvin stares at it
for a moment then picks it up hello he
says the voice on the other line
responds hello Calvin Lucian my name is
the administrator I've been following
your work for some time now and I must
say I am impressed I have just been
informed that you have completed your
mission congratulations are in order
what the hell are you talking about
Calvin asks please listen says the voice
on the other line the man you just
killed was once in the same exact
position you are in now granted it was a
very long time ago but Aaron Siegel
originally was trying to destroy the
foundation that was until I convinced
him otherwise and now like Aaron Siegel
you will become the new head of the
foundation like how I will yells Calvin
I could hang up and walk away right now
would be done with all this you could
continues the administrator but if no
one is in charge of the SCP Foundation
millions of people will die if not
billions and then nobody would be there
to manage what comes after there is
silence from Calvin that's what I
thought says the administrator I look
forward to working with you Calvin
Lucian or should I say
05-1 the line goes dead
the arabora cycle one of the biggest
most legendary series of entries in the
history of the SCP Foundation we've
covered the events of this scp-001 epic
in six videos which we definitely
recommend you watch before this one to
avoid your brain exploding from the
sheer scope of it all because that's the
thing about the orborus cycle it's a
story so big sprawling and dense that it
can feel almost like an anomaly itself
whether you're immersed in the possible
origin of the broken God the sentient
black hole that can destroy the whole
universe or Calvin lucian's quest to
assassinate the o5 council it can
sometimes be difficult to see the forest
from the trees but worry not because
that's exactly why we're here today
we're going to step back and look at
this anomalous Odyssey as a whole and
ask the big question why is it all here
together what makes these four different
story lines the children the broken God
atonement and the way it ends one big
cycle as with anything involving the SCP
Foundation there's always going to be an
element of personal interpretation but
now that we've gone through the whole
cycle we think it's worth adding our two
cents to the proceedings so let's start
broad a question you've probably been
wondering is what do the words or Boris
cycle actually mean and what is their
significance to the four stories within
well the spelling can differ or Boris
refers to the ancient symbol of a snake
or dragon eating its own tail forming a
circle a direct connection to the
concept of Cycles the r bar symbol has
existed in a huge number of cultures
from the ancient Egyptians to the
ancient Greeks to Modern Gnostic
Traditions it's often used in alchemy or
other magical practices and has a
variety of meanings such as eternal life
the endless cycle of death and rebirth
and the cycle of renewal anyone familiar
with the tales within the orboros cycle
is probably already noticing some
similarities Cycles are a common theme
in all of these Works people endlessly
repeat mistakes threats thought to be
contained or destroyed return and often
times those who go out on a quest to
destroy something end up becoming what
they wish to destroy in the first place
in a cycle there is no true end and no
true beginning everything repeats
endlessly but let's start at the closest
thing to the beginning we have the
children in this Tale the foundation
faces off against a terrifying reality
warping group of interests known as the
kingdom of Abaddon this nasty Group
which came from the Sahara Desert could
seemingly take anything the foundation
through at them and were able to
straight up vaporize anyone who got too
close if the kingdom was able to amass
enough power it could spell the end of
the foundation and even the subjugation
of the human race enter 05-1 a
reoccurring character in the orboro
cycle this outside the box thinker put
all his chips on the twins of God
project designated
scp-001 like many anomalies before and
after it this project would Infuse a
human being with Godlike Powers but it
was a power so great that it seemed to
kill anyone who attempted to accept it
needless to say this was a major bummer
for 05-1 but through Relentless human
experimentation even sacrificing the
population of entire towns to the
project he eventually came up with a
solution a horrifying solution but a
solution nonetheless he found that a
group of nine children with ages varying
from 4 to 11 could act as a human
conduit for 001's power and as a result
it could be a weapon capable of turning
the tide against the kingdom of Abaddon
during the testing phase though it
seemed like 05-1 went a little mad with
power he vaporized an entire church of
the broken God place of worship and used
the power of the children to wipe a few
others off the map at his own discretion
his abuses of power got so flagrant that
the administrator himself was called in
to get a handle on the situation and
surprise surprise 05-1 disintegrated him
too before disappearing himself shortly
afterwards in the end the children were
deemed too dangerous to be practical
both because of their anomalous powers
and from the level of ambient radiation
they put out all nine were locked in
radiation-proof boxes and buried in the
desert though they each show signs of
life to this day while this may seem
disconnected from the rest of the series
it actually establishes some of the most
important reoccurring themes and ideas
of this cycle as a whole namely the
foundation messing with reality and
Performing horrific acts to achieve
their goals the corruption of the o5
council and the fact that these Grand
attempts to change or save the world
often blow up in everyone's Faces
Sometimes literally we also have the
introduction and apparent death of the
mysterious administrator but trust us
all Is Not What It Seems with this one
the ripple effect beginning here will
affect everything going forward next the
broken in God this tells the chaotic
story of a magical Clockwork box which
is worshiped by the church of the broken
God as a conduit to their deity and
eventually becomes an all-devouring
mechanical Kaiju the Beast soon dubbed
scp-001 devoured and consumed all the
metal around it slowly becoming larger
and more destructive if the foundation
didn't take it out before it reached
critical mass they'd be going Toe to Toe
with a bona fide God a fight they really
weren't sure they could win thankfully
and with a little anomalous help from
scp-2399 the foundation was able to
destroy the anomaly They removed its
Clockwork hard from the wreckage and
contained the anomalous crap that once
comprised its destructive body however
the foundation soon realized that you
just can't keep a good god down the
Clockwork heart eventually evaded
Foundation containment while being
shipped to a secondary location and
instead ended up in a small town here it
began to influence the minds of the
residents into more sub servient broken
God cultists intense on building him
back up to his former glory it'd be easy
to Discount the broken God as an outlier
seeing as the foundation came out
looking much better here than they do in
any of the other orboros Tales but when
you look carefully it's placed in the
overall cycle is clear the entry ends
the way it begins with the heart of the
broken God influencing humans to carry
out its bidding the foundation had to
intervene in between these two instances
but in the end there was no net loss to
the broken God itself in a sense the
foundation is doomed to encounter the
same problems again and again
continually defending the world from the
same anomalous threats and the
foundation needs to succeed every time
to maintain peace and normality a major
anomalous threat only needs to succeed
once to drag everything into disarray in
many ways that is the curse of the SCP
Foundation speaking of major anomalous
threats now it's time for part three of
the orboro cycle atonement once again we
start off with the foundation meddling
with Cosmic scale Powers with the
creation of the area 11 pietrocal
Fontaine spatial stabilization array try
saying that three times fast that was
the machine so powerful it was capable
of creating a singularity though what it
actually ended up doing was turning Dr
Calvin Desmond into an Abomination more
specifically into a kind of immensely
powerful humanoid black hole whose
Powers were only restrained by the very
machine that created him think of him as
kind of a malicious Dr Manhattan from
Watchmen this new entity dubbed scp-001
presented a grim prophecy and an ominous
offer he told the o5 council that
anomalies were leaking into their
Universe from other realities and soon
the anomalous threat would destroy them
all his offer was to upon his release
wipe out the rest of the Multiverse
entirely leaving only our reality free
from anomalous threats unse surprisingly
it was 05-1 that was most interested in
this offer so much so that he held a
vote and murdered everyone who voted
against the decision to release
scp-001 having built his consensus among
the survivors on the council 05-1 let
scp-001 out unsurprisingly this turned
out to be a terrible decision as one of
his first acts upon being freed was to
kill the members of the o5 council that
had just voted to release zero zero one
saying that they themselves were
anomalous and needed to be purged to
atone for their past sins the only
Survivor was a member of the council who
abstained from the vote who was able to
recontain
scp-001 inside the Pietro Cal Fontaine
array for now once again the Thematic
connections to the rest of the orboro
cycle is clear we have a world-ending
anomaly held off but only temporarily
buying time before the cycle inevitably
continues we have the foundation abusing
its power and signing off on the death
of countless people in other dimensions
and of course the o5 council stepped out
of their bounds and actively warped
reality just like they had with the
children before their chickens truly
come home to roost though in the final
part of the cycle appropriately named
the way it ends this piece Chronicles
the story of Calvin Lucian and the kill
Squad an elite group of four chaos
Insurgency Soldiers with one goal
assassinating the entire o5 Council 13
of the most powerful people in the world
why because they've been messing with
reality itself time and time again and
it's getting to the point that their
selfish meddling could finally destroy
everything and given that we've already
seen it happen with the children and the
entity that Dr Calvin Desmond became
it's hard to disagree with them what
follows is one of the longest and most
complicated tales in all of the
foundation as the kill Squad
systematically encounters and kills each
insane anomalous member of the o5
council in order to do this they need to
make deals with death itself fight giant
serpents cross Dimensions deal with
scp-610 and scp-682 containment breaches
and go toe-to-toe with samsara arguably
the foundation's deadliest mobile task
force a number of other insane things
happen along the way like 05-1 murdering
the gate Guardian with the Scranton
reality anchor and the black queen the
most prominent member of the Serpent's
hand helping our heroes defeat more over
Sears in the end Calvin Lucien despite
losing almost everything Reigns
victorious in the final battle using the
Spear of the non-believer a weapon so
powerful it can kill Gods Calvin managed
to finally kill the Top member of the
overseers
05-1 with the o5 council destroyed
Calvin said about completing his final
task destroying the entire SCP
Foundation but that didn't happen
instead he was contacted by a mysterious
and immensely powerful being known as
the the administrator who gave him some
frightening news he'd just been hired by
the SCP Foundation to be their new 05-1
this was where our last video on the
arboros series left us what happens next
you may ask how does Calvin respond to
this offer he seemingly can't refuse in
this case it seems that the
administrator of being so completely
tied to the nature of the foundation
itself is
scp-001 and while it seemed that the
overseers were mad with power they were
actually always there to keep the
administrator in check Aaron Siegler the
05-1 that Calvin had just killed was
doing the exact same thing Calvin was
doing when he became 05-1 trying to
destroy the foundation but the
foundation and the administrator cannot
be beaten they can only be joined and
that's exactly what Calvin did becoming
the new 05-1 turning his back on the
chaos Insurgency and rebuilding the rest
of the council and the Fem foundation in
his own image Insurgency members who
were once his allies vowed revenge for
this betrayal perhaps suggesting that
history would go on to repeat itself
once more in the future because at the
end of the day that's what the oboro
cycle really is the reoccurring threat
and the changing of the guards that
accompanies it there will always be a
foundation there will always be an
administrator there will always be an o5
Council nothing starts nothing ends all
that ever changes are the names and
faces involved whether it's Calvin
Lucian or Aaron Siegler the wheel keeps
turning the snake devours its own tail
the oboros cycle is and forever will be
Eternal now go check out our full piece
by piece breakdown on the oboro cycle
starting with scp-001 the children and
then check out
scp-5000y the full story compilation
just in case we haven't blown your mind
enough for one day